군대 갔는데 와우가 너무 하고 쓴거에요
바로 여기서 때릴 수 있다는 걸 자각을 해야 되는데
그치 그치
한국에선 좀 잘하는 회사가 있을까요?
한국에서요?
이거 한국 경제가 문제인거 아닌가요?
이 게임이 주는 교훈이 있다면?
이 게임이 주는 교훈은 총을 빨리 뽑아야 된다
안녕하십니까 비주류 초대서 오늘의 호스트를 맡게 된 김단지입니다
저는 재무도코 이재용이구요
뭐에요?
그 다음 멘트가 있습니다
오늘 비주류 초대석 주제는 게임입니다
게스트로 이종범 작가님 모셨습니다
안녕하십니까 이종범입니다 반갑습니다
아 진짜 불편한 오프닝이네요 너무 기대가 됩니다
종범님 저랑은 초면이시고
그렇죠 저는 너무 좋아하는 뮤지션이시지만
저도 이제 만화 너무 좋아하고
안경 수염
많은게 겹쳐요
그러니까요
같은 성분인데 배합을 좀 다르게 한 느낌이죠
정감있는 게스트분
그러니까요
처음이랑은 다르게 합이 맞는 게스트
민경님 때도 너무 재밌게 봤는데요
아 그 사람 얘기 하지도 마십시오
종범이 원래 만화 그리기 전에 드러머를 하신거에요?
그쵸 그 전 직업이었죠
전 직업이였어요?
만화가 하기 전에 거쳤던 직업들이 여러개인데요
아예 풀타임 연주자로 직업을 갖고 있었구요
아 원래 만화도 전공이 아니고 드럼도 전공이 아니신거죠?
심리학이신거죠?
심리학이 전공이죠
네 그쵸
그리고 악기를 시작했다가
아
너무 끝까지 가버린 케이스에요
아 진짜요?
만화 그릴 때는 한 번도 칭찬을 받아본 적이 없는데
악기를 잡았는데 다 선생님들이 잘한다 그러니까 괜히 뽕 차가지고
이게 내 길인가? 그리고 착각을 한거죠
제가 이제 같은 업종으로 말씀드리자면
이 드럼은 너무 귀해가지고
아 플레이어가?
네 일단은 잘한다 잘한다 한 다음에 키워서 써야되거든요
아 그쵸 그쵸
키워서 잡아먹는
네
그게 있기 때문에
베이스랑
거기에 홀랑 넘어가셨네요
그쵸 그쵸
그냥 영업 당해가지고
참 안타깝다
저 지금도 드럼 사랑하는데요
사랑은 해요 사랑하시죠
아 근데 오늘 진짜 게임 얘기라고 하셔가지고 솔직히 달려왔어요
음
저는 비주류 경제학 원래 좋아하긴 했지만 게임 얘기라고 하면 버틸 수가 없는 주제이기 때문에
저도 어디가서 게임 얘기하기가 좀 어렵거든요
그쵸 그쵸
저희가 또 어른이잖아요 이제
가끔 의심합니다만 저는
네 어디가서 게임 얘기를 꺼내기가 조금
그쵸
네 하지만 오늘 딱 자리를 만들어 줬으니까
네
저희 셋이 신나게 게임 얘기를 하는 걸로
어쨌든 저희가 이제 같은 그 시대를 좀 경험을 했다 보니까 언제부터 게임의 세계로 이끌었는지 이런 거를 좀 얘기해 보면 좋을 것 같아요
네 좋죠 좋죠
일단은 저 같은 경우는 어릴 때 패밀리라고 그러죠
패밀리
페미컴
네 갈비트 게임기 12년을 패밀리만 하다가
중간에 뭐 메가 드라이브 세가세 같은 거 다 건너뛰고 그냥
그런 거 다 못했어요 그런 거 다 이제 옆집 친구들 하는 거 구경하고
저는 너무 열받는 거죠
쟤네는 슈퍼마리오 카트를 하고 있는데
너무 화가 나서 돈을 한 1년을 모아가지고
정말 중고 플레이스테이션 17만 원 주고 샀던 기억이 있거든요
그게 몇 살 때라고요
그게 이제 6학년에서 중1 넘어가는 겨울방학
아 진짜
돈 많이 모았다
그러게요
진짜로 거짓말 안 하고 병을 팔아서 돈을 모았거든요
네 그때는 맥주병 팔았지
델몬트 병 같은 거 있잖아요
델몬트 제일 비쌌지
제일 비쌌죠
오락실은 안 가셨어요?
오락실은 그냥 저의 제2의 학교였어요
어릴 때는 게임 잡지 기자도 하고 싶었어요
그쵸 게임 피아 막 해가지고 CD 주고 막 번들로
게임 라인 뭐 이래가지고
진심이었네
정말 진심이었지만
저희때는 생일잔치를 오락실에서 했어요
어떻게 했냐면 시내에 있는 롯데리아에서 햄버거 한식 딱 먹고
그 다음에 엄마가 한 3만 원 주시거든요
그걸로 이제 오락실 가서 100원짜리를 바꾼 다음에
나눠줘 친구들한테
아 배급해가지고
야 너는 나랑 좀 더 친하니까 너는 500원
이렇게 나눠줘
이상한데요
어 그게 페스티벌
게임 페스티벌
근데 엄격하게 통제당하던 시절이었어요
전 지금도 얘기하거든요
학부모들이 많이 오는 행사에서 이런 얘기를 해요
당신의 자녀가 평생 동안 뭔가에 집착하게 하고 싶잖아요
지금 철저히 금지해라
못하게 하면 커서 더 한다
지금 제 작업실 와보신 분들 아시죠?
작업실 들어가는 순간 금지당한 걸로 쫙
억압된 나의 유년생활이
그럼 각자 우리 학창시절에 제일 재밌게 했던 게임 한번 정리해볼까요?
아 이거 너무 많은데요
관진이 뭐 생각나는 거 있으세요?
저는 이제 그 파이널 판타지 세븐을
파이널 판타지 세븐
와 이거 문화유산인데
저는 정말로 제 인생에 굉장히 중요한 부분이라고 생각합니다
그럼요 어떻게 에어리스와 티파를 하면
당연히 티파죠
네 알겠습니다
에어리스 이 배신자는
파이널 판타지 세븐을 인생게임으로 꼽는 사람만 모아도 한 국가를 만들 수 있어요
게임 업계의 전문가들도 그렇게 얘기 많이 하고
왜냐면은 저 파이널 판타지 세븐을 중심으로 놓고
스토리, 캐릭터, 게임 시스템, 전투 시스템
거의 모든 것들이 한번 크게 바뀌거든요
저걸 기점으로 나누는 사람도 많아요
종범님 학창시절에 저를 뭘 많이 하셨어요?
제 학창시절을 완벽히 지배했던 게임은
레인보우 식스였어요
어? 그건 또 잔인한데?
저는 레인보우 식스를 거의 운동부 애들이 훈련하듯이
선으로 만들어 놓은 상태에 각으로 이 그래네이드 넣기
이런 걸 연습을 하던 사람이란 말이에요
대회에 나가서
저는 게임 덕분에 사람들하고 소통하는 법을 배웠어요
왜냐면은 팀 짜서 가야 되잖아요
지금 레인보우 식스 하려면
여기서 누가 못하면
쿠사리를 주면 안 할 거 아니에요
그럼 이제 북돋아 줘야 되고
서로서로 그렇게 공동의 목표를 해가고 있다
근데 저와 조금 다른 게
예전에 저희 세대는 PC방에 가서
우리가 다 같이 얼굴을 아는 상태로 가잖아요
그러니까 누가 먼저 죽어도
야 그 다음엔 또 열심히 하면 돼 이러는 건데
요즘은 죽으면
안부를 물어보죠
안부를
막 하루에도 부모님이 몇 번씩 막 살았다 없어졌다 막 해요
이게 얼굴이 안 보이니까
맞아요
바로 여기서 때릴 수 있다는 걸 자각을 해야 되는데
그치 그치
이게 사람들이 그게 좀 많이
우리 오락실에서 예의 지켰잖아요 우리가
우리가 예의를 지키는 이유는
지금 바로 때릴 수 있으니까 예의를 지키는 거잖아요
형이 저 앞에 있으니까
요즘 저는 온라인 게임 못해요 무서워서
그래서 저는 그 마지막 협동심을 느꼈던 게
월드 오브 워크래프트
아 그쵸 그쵸 그쵸 그쵸
군대 가기 전까지
몸무게가 한 90kg 됐나
먹고
와우하고
내 캐릭터가 대신 움직여서
먹고 내 캐릭터들이 대신 달려주고
그니까 저도 와우에 대한 얘기 중에
군대 갔는데
군대 갔는데 와우가 너무 하고 싶은 거예요
차를 팔아냈어요?
팔 수 없잖아
이건 관심 영상이에요
그건 아닌데
그래서 게임 잡지를 막 보면서 연구를 해
그 다음 그때는 파티원이 다섯 명이었어요
그러니까 다섯 명 외박 나갈 친구들을 모아요
아
그래가지고
우리 외박 나가면 그때 토요일날 9시에 나와서
일요일날 9시에 들어가야 돼요
딱 36시간 체류하거든요
그쵸 그쵸
자 우리 다섯 명 나가서 이제
그 첫 번째 인스턴트 던전이라고 하는 죽음의 폐강이라는 데가 있어요
아 그쵸
레벨 20을 찍어야 돼
대피하지도 않네
그치
레벨 20을 찍고 폐강을 돌고 거기를 클리어하고 오자 해가지고
36시간 동안 30시간 PC방을 했어요
종범님 근데 그 소울유 되게 좋아하지 않으세요?
프롬소프트의 자식이고
망자라고 하면 진짜 아실 거예요
아 그럼요 그럼요 유다이
망자라 불러요 망자
아 유다이
최근에는 그래서 이제 네오비즈의 피해거주인 한국이 만든 걸작 소울라이크이기 때문에
이곳에서 주로 살았던 것 같아요
아 그래요
이야기가 있고 캐릭터가 있고 명확한 엔딩이 있는
맞아
콘솔 게임 작품만 하면서 산 게 이제 2002년 3년 그때부터 43이 될 때까지
딱 그럼 살다가 최근에 다시 그냥 온라인 게임을 하거든요
저의 인생 게임은 전부 다 콘솔의 명작들이 많아요
딱 두 분 다 너무 좋아하실 만한 그런 게임이 많아요
GTA5라고
아 GTA5
아 아 트레버 설명회랑 하고 싶용
아 정말요
예
저는 근데 저도 GTA 너무 좋아하고
아 그렇죠
이 락스타게임즈의 게임 다 너무 좋아해가지고 놀랐던 게 LA를 한번 갔었는데
네
LA에서 이렇게 빡 가다가 천문대를 저희가 갔었거든요
근데 제가 딱 보다가 어 나 이거 어디서 봤는데
야 여기서 왼쪽으로 하면 천문대 나온다 진짜 나온 거에요
그래서 벤잡이
GTA5였어요
맞아 맞아
자동차 타고 간 그 곳이 너무 많이 가가지고
그런 정도로 이 게임을 너무 잘 만들었어요.
이건 이제 하나의 게임이 아니라 세계, 그리고 나의 하나의 삶.
맞아요. 우리가 옛날 생각해보면 정리해보면
파이널 판타지 좋아하시고 창세기존도 재밌고
GTA나 갓 오브 워도 그렇고 뭔가 이렇게
세계관이 되게 뚜렷하고 되게 스토리가 재밌잖아요.
그렇죠.
옛날에는 왜 그렇게 재밌는 게임이 많았을까요?
지금도 많지 않아요.
지금도 많지 않아요? 많은가?
게임에 대해 얘기할 때 항상 그 당시 사춘기였던 사람들은
당시에 자기의 삶이 딱 어떤 시기였는지가 중요한 것 같아요.
추억보정.
제일 게임 가지고 충격받았을 나이가 사춘기거든요.
조작하는 순간 내가 움직이니까
그렇죠. 그 안에 들어가죠.
너무 빠르게 내가 내 자신이 돼버려서
다른 콘텐츠들에 비해서 각인효과가 너무 큰 게 느껴져요.
저는 근데 그에 반해서 요즘 나오는 게임들 중에
너무 막 만드는 게 많아서 저는 문제가 있다는 생각도 있거든요.
화나신 거 아니죠, 지금?
네.
저는 화를 낸 적이 없습니다. 한 번도.
그래서 이 막 만든다는 게 뭐냐면
이 게임이라는 거를 우리가 작품으로서 소비를 하는 형태가
저희 어릴 적에는 좀 있었다는 생각이 있어요.
그러니까 왜냐하면 저도 예전에 계속했던 게임들을 보면
그 메탈기어 솔리드 끝에 보면 엔딩에 이 각본 누구 뭐
이 멋있는 작품으로 만들어야지 그때 소비를 하는 형태였으니까
지금은 어떻게든 우리를 여기에
깊게끔 과금을 유도한다든지 혹은 모래에 머물 수 있는 장치들을 심어놓고
장치에만 너무 치중해 놓은 게임들이 좀 많단 말이죠.
뻔한 BM들.
네. 뻔한 BM들. 총 왼쪽으로 쏘다가 오른쪽으로 쏘다가 뿅뿅뿅뿅 하다가
결국에는 죽게 되는 그런 것들이 있잖아요.
이게 게임이 맞아, 얘가 이게?
니네 게임 안 좋아하잖아 라는 걸 게임으로서 느끼는 거야.
만드는 사람들한테. 야, 니네 진짜 양심이 있냐?
너 이런 걸 게임이라고 만들어 왔어?
다시? 다시 여기까지 가는 거야?
몰라요.
과거에 생각해보면 그런 것도 있었을 것 같아요.
대안이 별로 없었어요. 하나를 하면 끝까지 가야 되는 거야.
그러다 보니까 이제 게임 제작자도 플레이어의 상황에 따라
기승전결을 만들 수가 있어요.
요즘은 대안이 너무 많고 언제든지 떠날 수 있으니까
그리고 무료 게임도 많고 하니까
그 기승전결 안에 그걸 놓기에는 감당하기가 좀 쉽지 않다.
요즘 게임들이 그래서 도입부에서는 주인공이 강한 상태가 있고
그 기승전결로 나와서 필살기 다 쓰고
시작하면 너프돼서 모든 힘을 입고 도전당했다, 이러고 시작해요.
그래야지 뒤쪽에 가면 사실 쓸 수 있는 겁니까? 기대감으로 가는 거거든요.
어떻게 보면 이제 게임 업계에서도 재무쟁이들이 이제 점령을 한 지가 오래됐거든요.
왜냐하면 이제 게임 회사들이 점점 커지고 스케일이 커지다 보니까
굴러다니는 돈이 막 조단위로 굴러다니니까
그 재무쟁이들이 문제인 것 같아요.
재무쟁이들이 언제나 문제예요.
뭐든 사놓으면 재무쟁이가 문제예요.
계산기로 하거든. 엑셀로 두드려가지고. 야, 이거 지금 이렇게 해서.
야, 이거 지금 이렇게 해서. 야, 이거 지금 이렇게 해서.
엑셀로 두드려가지고. 야, 이거 지금 이렇게 해서.
떠나면 매출 안 나올 거 아니야.
이런 식으로 하니까 게임이 재미가 없어지잖아.
삼성 원정대도 어떻게 보면 원래 유비소프트에 있던 개발자들이
퇴사해서 회사를 만든 거라고 그랬죠.
근데 유비에서는 그런 기획서 올리면 까여요.
아, 유비. 유비가 문제야. 유비 진짜야.
어떻게 보면 이제 대기업이 그런 재무쟁이들이 그런 참신한 기획들,
깊이 있는 스토리들 이런 거를 받아줄 환경이 아니라는 게
지금 게임계에 주어진 어떤 제일 큰 숙제이자
아쉬움인 것 같아요.
제이홍님 오셨으니까 눈물 흘리고 싶은 게
요즘 게임 산업이 전 세계적으로 어떤 느낌인가요?
원래는 게임 산업이 그래도 이 콘텐츠 내지는 어떤 문화 사업 측면에서 보면
약간 블루칩 같은 존재였어요. 잘 자란다. 성장이 죽지 않는다.
라고 했는데 요즘에는 조금 죽었어요.
한 2022년에서 2025년까지 연평균 시장 성장률이 한 2.8% 정도예요.
이 정도면 거의 그냥 물가 성장률.
우리가 흔히 보는 TV, 냉장고, 세탁기, 가전도 5% 정도 성장하는데
2.8%는 거의 멈췄다고 보셔도 될 것 같고요.
미래 전망도 그렇게 밝지 않습니다.
2025년에서 2028년까지도 한 3%
아무리 좋게 봐줘도 3% 올라갈 것 같다.
아무라네.
그래도 시장 규모는 작지는 않은데
277조 원, 글로벌하게 277조 원으로 작은 산업은 아닙니다.
분야별로 생각해보면 지금까지는 모바일이 굉장히 컸어요.
전체 시장에서 대략 한 55% 정도가 모바일이 됐어요.
그다음에 이제 24%가 콘솔, 21%가 PC로 나눠가졌었는데요.
앞으로의 전망은 콘솔 쪽이 한 4.7%대의 성장률이 나올 것 같다.
살짝 나왔네, 높네요.
그다음에 PC가 3.3%, 모바일이 2.6%.
오히려 모바일은 여기까지 다 온 것 같고.
콘솔이 높아요, 왜 높아요?
콘솔이 왜 높냐라고 생각해보면 딱 명확합니다.
이제 스위치2가 나온 지 얼마 안 됐어요.
아!
스위치, 이제 시작이거든요.
아직 타이틀 몇 개 안 나왔잖아요.
스위치가 콘솔계에 차지하는 비중이
이제 무심 못하기 때문에.
너무 크니까.
그게 또 닌텐도 스위치, 올드게이머들,
정통파들에게는 또 이게 인정 못하는 부분이잖아요.
못하지만 사실 할 수 있는 작품도 있죠.
저는 아주 좋아하는데요, 스위치.
있어요!
사실은 스위치 같은 게 굉장히 필요한 이유가
막 다 플스만 있고 액방만 있으면
우리 같은 사람밖에 게임계에 안 남아요.
그러면 우리 같은 사람이 늙으면 시장이 죽을 수밖에 없잖아요.
근데 스위치가 이제 어린 유망주들을 이렇게 하면서 끌어오는데
이거 하다 보면
아빠, 그건 뭐야? 하다가 이제 젤다의 전설을 하는 걸 본단 말이지.
젤다 하다 보면 갑자기 또 뭔가 GTA도 하고 싶고 막 이럴 거 아니에요.
아빠가 출근하면서 치킨 사오듯이
스위치 소매에다가 뭐 다크 소요 가사가 넣어놓는다고요.
그러면 그게 그 아이의 인생으로도 결정하는 거지.
그래서 아마 스위치도 그렇고요.
지금까지는 2000년대 코로나 이후에 모바일이 굉장히 컸다라고 한다면
모바일은 조금 이제 얼만큼 왔다.
이미 전 세계 사람들이 할 만큼 다 했고
또 요즘 젊은 사람들은 게임을 좀 덜 한다.
그럼 남은 거는 우리 같은 구매력 있는 아저씨들이.
영포트들이 영피부티가 될 때까지 콘솔 게임을 하는 게
게임 시장의 전망 아니겠는가라고 저는 일단 그렇게 유치를 해봤습니다.
암울하네요.
일본 회사들은 상황이 좀 어떤가요?
네, 이제 국가별로 좀 상황을 보면 좋을 것 같은데
일본 회사들은 참고로 상황이 좋습니다.
딱 봐도 이제 주가 그래프 제가 4개 회사를 해놨는데
닌텐도 같은 경우는 이제 스위치2가 나오면서
역대급 판매량을 갱신하면서 성과가 굉장히 좋고요.
앞단에 한 4년 동안 평탄하게 그리잖아요.
매출이 항상 일정하게 따박따박 나오는 대명사예요.
그래서 절대 망하지 않는 회사가 닌텐도고
캡콤은 몬스터 헌터 와일즈가 나왔죠.
역시 역대급 판매량이 나오고
케어이닉스는 다양한 시도하다가 안 좋아서
이제 요즘의 전략을 보여준 거는
아, 우리 파이널 판타지나 드래곤 퀘스트 같은
검증된 IP에 집중하겠다.
플러스 우리가 그동안 플스에 주로 했는데
PC도 요즘 대부분 다 동시 출시하거든요.
PC까지 내면 이제 플스 없는 저 같은 사람들도 할 수 있으니까
그런 쪽으로 가겠다 해서 주가가 한번 딱 반등했고요.
반다이 남콘은 사실은 게임에 살아기보다는
완구회사에 가까웠지만 게임도 적지는 않거든요.
작년에 엘드닝 굉장히 잘 팔렸고
올해는 드래곤볼 스파킹 제로가 나오면서
잘 나오면서 또 역시 주가가 올라가고
원래 게임회사의 인식은 좀 위험하다.
왜냐면 잘 되고 안 될 때 안 되는데
일본 회사들은 IP가 굉장히 많아요.
그러니까 신작들 내보내면서 계속 중첩되면서
매출이 올라가거나 정 안 되면 이제 꺼내면 돼요.
뭐요? 리메이크.
리메이크 꺼내면 바로 매출 반등하거든요.
그래서 일본 기업들은
앞으로 망할 일도 없고
이제 유리한 위치를 차지하고 있다고 보면 될 것 같아요.
그다음에 이제 다른 나라들은 어떤지
유럽은 대표적으로 최근에 다른 방송에서도 언급을 했는데
유비. 유비 소프트가 원래 유럽의 일장이었거든요.
유럽의 자존심이었죠.
유럽의 일장이었는데
원래 이제 제일 높았을 때 주가가 주당 100유로였는데
지금 최근에 조회해보니까 6유로 나와요.
100유로에서 6유로.
제가 제 10대를 받쳤던 레인보우 식스가 아니라.
아 그쵸. 레인보우 식스.
어세싱 크리드.
파크라이 되게 좋았네.
잘 나가는데 이제 그 알짜들을 최근에 이제 텐센트에 일부 지붕 매각하면서 같이 하기로 했어요.
그다음에 이제 그나마 이제 CD 프로젝트.
위쳐.
싸펑.
위쳐3가 2015년에 나왔고.
싸펑이 이제 2020년에 나왔거든요.
이제 위쳐4는 2016년에 안 나온대요.
안 나온대요?
안 나온대요.
신의사가 언제 나오는 거죠?
제가 볼 때 2020년에.
2017 하반기 정도 봐야 돼.
아무리 빨라도.
어 그렇지만.
그렇지만 특이하게도 겨우 그 두 타이틀이 메인인 회사가.
거의 영업이익률 한 30-40% 나오거든요.
왜 그러냐?
계속 사요.
아무리 욕을 해도 위쳐3랑 싸이버펑크가 명작인 거는.
어쩔 수 없죠.
싸이버펑크 맨 처음 나왔을 때.
진짜 개탄했습니다.
이거 이 새끼들이 뭐.
저게 이제 설레가 돼가지고.
요즘에 저 따라하는 제작사가 너무 많거든요.
엉망으로 내놓고 고치겠다.
일단 엉망으로 팍 해놓은 다음에.
고치면 될 거 아니야.
나중에 잘할게.
근데 그렇게 해서 고쳐지는 회사가 있고.
안 고쳐지는 회사가 있죠.
저희 프로젝트는 고친다.
그래서 이제 여기는 주가 계속 오른다.
믿고 있습니다.
그다음에 이제 중국 얘기도 한번 해보면.
중국이야 뭐.
이제는 해야 돼요.
이제는 중국 얘기 해야 됩니다.
중국이 최고죠.
원래 사실 중국을 조금 무시하는.
어떤 그런 상황이었죠.
맞아요.
예전에는.
근데 이젠 아니다.
중국의 특징은 굵직한 회사만 꼽아도 그렇지만.
게임 회사가 엄청 많고.
내수가 엄청나고.
맞아요.
하나 딱 만들면 조 단위의 매출을 착 뽑을 수 있어요.
원신이 거의 따박따박 한 2조 원 정도의 매출을 낸다고 알려져 있거든요.
아주 효자예요 효자.
또 재밌는 특징이 중국 사람들이 진짜 자본주의적이거든요.
딜레마이네요.
아이러니하게.
예를 들어서 내가 만약에 대작 게임을 만들었어요.
매출액이 잘 터지면 1조 나와요.
내가 한 천억 받아요.
그게 되는 게 중국이에요.
그 경쟁이 엄청 치열하지만.
그 안에서 이제 그 보상 때문에라도 더 열심히 하는 게 있어서.
지금은 어떻게 보면 한국 게임 회사보다.
게임 회사들이 더 퀄리티도 높고 다양성도 뛰어나고.
좀 되게 배 아프기도 하고 부럽기도 합니다.
그럼 그렇게 따지면 이제 한국에선 좀 잘하는 회사가 있을까요?
한국 회사요?
조금 이제 걱정되는데.
다른 제가 보여드린 그래프는 다 파란색, 빨간색이었는데.
한국은 전반적으로 파란색이죠.
그러네요.
파란색 떨어졌다.
이거 한국 경제가 문제인 거 아닌가요?
한국 경제의 문제이기도 하고 게임의 문제이기도 합니다.
기본적으로 요즘 이제 크래프톤이.
네.
지금 한국 게임을 많이 보고 있는 이유가 주가가 많이 떨어지고 있어요.
그러네요.
여기도 이제 30만 원대 중반에서 지금 20만 원대 중반까지 올해 쭈루루룩 내려오고 있는 이유가 배그가 워낙 잘 돼요.
거의 1년에 조 단위씩 캐시를 벌어오는데.
근데 거기서 이제 세컨 작품이 뭐가 나왔냐.
올해 초 인조이 조금 나오다가 인조이도 사실 콘텐츠 너무 부족해서 다시 이제 쑥 들어가고.
서브노티카도 지금 막 소송 싸우고 있고 안 좋거든요.
그러니까 뭔가 그 세컨 게임이 나올락 말락, 나를락 말락 하는데 안 나옵니다.
음.
그리고.
응.
다 아시죠.
여기도 100만 원을 찍었던 회사가 지금 19만 원 정도 찍고 있으니까.
전설의 시대였는데 그때.
네.
활로를 아직 잘 못 찾고 있다.
음.
유일하게 잘 나가는 회사는 우리나라에서는 대기업 중에는 넥슨이 거의 유일하기도 하고.
넥슨.
넥슨이 여기는 진짜 오랫동안 우상향하는 기업이거든요.
메이플, 던파, FC 온라인이 이제 매출액의 상당 부분을 가져와주고.
그러니까 실적 안정성이 굉장히 좋은 회사인데.
최근에 좀 두 개가 터졌습니다.
아크레이더스 터졌고요.
아크레이더스.
메이플 키위가 지금 얼마 동안.
지금.
키위인지 모르겠어요.
네.
그래서 그게 이제 양대 마켓에서 1등을 굉장히 오랫동안 하고 있어서.
탄탄한 IP 위에 새로운 신작들이 착착착착 추가되면서.
성장하는 그림을 만들고 있는 회사는 한국에는 넥슨.
넥슨밖에 없겠네요.
대기업 중에는.
근데 그 저 갑자기 생각나는 데이브 더 다이브가 나왔을 때.
어 그래도 한국에서 이 정도의 어떤 열의가 아직 있다라는 느낌을 좀 받았어요.
그러니까요.
그 게임에 대해서.
맞아요.
이게 돈 벌기 위해서 만들었다는 게임이라는 느낌을 못 받았죠.
개발하는 사람들이 계속 웃으면서 만들었겠네.
잠은 못 잤죠.
이건 지들이 좋아서 만들었겠네 라는 느낌을 좀 받는 게.
맞아요.
어 간만에 너무 좋았었던 기억이 있어요.
넥슨 같은 경우는 사내에 역시 돌고 있는 프로젝트가 굉장히 많다고 알려져 있고.
어떻게 보면 데이브 더 다이버가 그런 뭔가 변화의 어떤 시작점이었던 것 같아요.
아마 저도 이제 기사에서 찾아보기로는 돈은 생각하지 말고 재밌는 거 한번 만들어봐 했는데.
진짜 재밌는 게 나와서 재무적으로도 좀 도움이 많이 됐고.
또 그거를 필두로 이제 신작들이 계속.
계속 이제 실험적인 것들이 계속 나오는데 다 괜찮게 나오거든요.
지금 제가 판교로 출근을 많이 해요 실제로.
판교에 어떤 바람이 불고 있냐면 말씀하셨던 데이브 더 다이버 이후에 스토리, 내러티브가 전문적이지 않고 체계적이지 않다는 걸 인정하자 분위기가 지금 판교에 돌고 있어요.
그러면서 어떻게 되냐면 아예 내러티브를 전업으로 갖고 있는 프로페셔널들에게 얘기를 해서 같이 협업을 하든 랩으로 데리고 오든 아예 내러티브 한번 이거 리셋해야 되는데 라는 분위기가 전반적으로 대기업사에서 돌고 있는데.
저는 개인적으로 길게 보면 한 번 르네상스 오지 않는다는 기대감이 있어요.
스토리를 중시하기 시작하니까.
맞아요. 어떻게 보면 이제 여러 번 얘기하긴 했는데 이제 한국 게임에는 그동안 상징적인 리니지의 비즈니스 모델이 이제는 좀 정리되는 시점이 아닌가라는.
그동안 2000년대, 2020년대에 리니지가 너무 많은 돈을 벌다 보니까.
맞아요.
한국에는 모든 게임 회사들이 다 리니지예요.
네.
비스무리한 걸 만들었거든요.
그래서 뭘 하든 자꾸
요즘에는 기자들이 비즈니스 모델 물어보잖아요.
사실 게임한테 비즈니스 모델을 물어보는 게
저는 이상하다고 생각해요.
재미를 물어봐야지.
그래도 재밌으면
사람들은 언젠간 알아주는 거죠.
그렇죠. 언젠가는 찾는다.
쉐이프 오브 드림이라는 게임이 있어요.
최근에 한 9월에 출시돼서
50만 장이 팔린 게임인데
한국에 대학생 두 명이 창업해서 만든 게임이에요.
그분들이 마케팅 예산이 있어? 뭐가 있어?
그냥 올렸는데 재밌으니까
입소문이 나서 팔리고
그리고 이제 산나비.
산나비.
산나비 정말 재밌었는데
거기도 원더포션이라는 제작사에서 만들었는데
처음에 그 제작사가 5명이서 만들었습니다.
진짜요?
그런데 200만 장 넘게 팔렸거든요.
요즘 트렌드는 작은 인원으로 제작하더라도
작품성이 좋으면 입소문이 나서
잘 팔리는 것 때문에
어떻게 보면 좋은 게임과
어떻게 보면 잘 팔리는 게임이
점점 일치하고 있는 것 같아요.
그러네요.
그런데 요즘 릴스, 쇼츠 시대다 보니까
10대, 20대들이 게임을 잘 안 한다고 하더라고요.
그게 실제로도 그런가요?
아니요. 제가 말이죠.
그렇게 들었어요.
학교 선생님 하시는 분들
친구나 지인 중에서
형, 요즘에 학교에서 공부 잘하는 애들
전교에서 노는 애들은
다 웹툰 요청소리를 봐.
그래서 뭔 소리 하는 거야?
잘못 얘기한 거 아니야?
그러면 공부 못하는 애들은 뭘 봐?
쇼츠랑 릴스만 봐.
아...
쇼츠랑 릴스는 모두가 다 보는데
오직 그것만 보는 애들은
확실히 뭔가 퍼포먼스가 떨어지고
그 사이사이에 게임도 하고
웹툰, 웹소절도 보고
이런 애들은 차례대로 공부를 잘하더라.
그런 얘기를 들으면서
이게 확실히 쇼츠랑 릴스가
우리 뇌를 확 데려가긴 하지.
그러니까 웹툰은 조금 더 액티브한 활동인 거고
해석하고, 인입하고
쇼츠는 그냥 받아들이는
되게 수동적인 활동인 거니까
맞아요. 맞아요.
그래서 지금 시기에 쇼츠랑 릴스에 절여진
그 세대 어떡할 거야?
그런 얘기 많이 하죠.
네. 네.
아, 그러니까 쉽지는 않네요.
저는 질문을 뒤집어 보면
우리가 고전소설이 좋지만
고전소설을 안 읽는 이유랑도 비슷한 것 같아요.
왜냐하면 고전소설 좋은 거 알잖아요.
뭔가 서사적으로 완벽한 내용을 써놨는데
우리가 안 보잖아요.
왜 안 보시죠?
어려우니까.
지루해서요.
지루하니까.
그림이 없어서.
그치. 그 세계관 안에 들어가는데
스트레스를 많이 받으니까.
두뇌를 많이 써야 되니까.
그렇지만 그걸 보게 되면
오래 걸린 만큼
얻을 수 있는 쾌감의 크기도 큰 것 같아요.
그렇죠.
그렇기 때문에
저는
갓겜이라고 할 수 있는 고전이 됐든
최근 게임이 됐든
뭐 좀 대작기라고 할 수 있는 것들은
해봐도 좋다.
해봐야 한다 보다는
꼭 해야 되는 건 아니지만
인생에 전혀 해가 되지 않을 뿐더러
오히려 삶의 경험을 더 풍부하게 만들어줄 것 같아요.
그럼 저희가 이제
세 명의 어떤
애착게이머?
뭐라고 그러지?
애게이머?
네.
이상해.
잠깐.
최애게임.
네.
그런 어떤 게임에 대해서
한 명씩
자신의
최애게임을 소개하는
시간을 좀
가져오면 어떨까
너무 좋습니다.
너무 좋다.
너무 힘들었어요.
왜요?
하나를 선택한 게
굳이 하나를 꼽으라고 하니까
그렇죠.
원래 이 비주류 초대석이 항상
그런 문제가 있습니다.
저의 어떤
제일 중요한 거 하나를 내놓으세요.
라고 했을 때
맞아요.
나 이거
얕보이면 안 되는데
저는 제일 좋아하는 거 가져왔는데
레드데드 리뎀션
명작이다.
전혀 얕보일 수 없는 픽이다.
그렇죠.
뭐 설명이 필요한가요?
이게
결국은
결국에는
서부시대에
갱단으로서의
일원으로서
살아가는 얘기인데
이 락스타게임즈가
결국에는
폭력적이고
잔인한
게임을 만들기로
유명한
그렇죠.
노빠쿠커버
레드데드 리뎀션도
그런 류의
게임이라고
우리가 생각했었거든요.
이제 얘네
서부에 가가지고
거기 사람들 다 죽이고
그 기대로 했는데
아니었어요.
그냥 이거는
죽이긴 하지만
갱단이기도 하지만
글쎄요.
뭐랄까
뭐
어떤 대부라고 할까요?
어떤 그 서사와
모든 것들이 완벽한
가족에 대한 얘기였다.
맞아요.
그래서
우리가 서부시대에
못 느끼잖아요.
네.
근데
해보면
이랬을 거라는 걸
알게 돼요.
진짜 그 냄새가 나요.
네.
정말로
냄새가 나요.
흙 냄새라고
제가 그 더치반더린드라는
주인공 갱단의
연대기를 파봤어요.
아무리 봐도
이 시기에
이렇게 태어났으면
인생 피할 길이 없어요.
그러니까 지금처럼 어디
열심히 공부해서
취업할 거야.
없는 시대.
양지로 갈 수 없다.
그러니까 철도로 연결되기 전에
서부시대 마지막 부분에
거기서 딱 태어났어요.
그러면 얘네가 살 수 있는 길이
서로 등쳐먹는 것밖에 없어요.
그렇죠.
우리는 이거밖에 없지
다른 길이 뭐가 있어라고 생각해서
살아오면서 나이를 먹었는데
세상이 그 사이 변해서
아닌데
제대로 된 삶을 살 기회가
여기 있는데
너네 몰랐네
이랬잖아요.
근데
얘들은 낀 세대예요.
맞아요.
이미 그 방식으로 살아서
세금 내고 제대로
합법적으로 살기에는
살 줄 몰라.
이미 너무
많이 왔고
맞아.
죄도 너무 많아.
얘는
죄도 아니야 심지어.
심지어 그래서 여기서
무법자랑
범죄자가 다르거든요.
범죄자는 크리미널이잖아요.
무법자는
outlaws라고 해서
법 바깥이라는 건데 뭐냐면
우리는 법이 없을 때 태어나서
지금 30대야.
법이 없었다고 얘들아.
근데 갑자기 법이 있다고
와버리니까
내가 잘못한 거야?
이렇게 된 거예요.
그러면서
누구는
마지막까지 정하고
그럼 내가 정산할게.
내가 지금까지 잘못한 거
피해준 거
정산할게.
이 선택을
우리한테 줘요.
그거 따라가다 보면 이제
구원을 받을 거냐
저주를 받을 거냐를
알게 되는 거지.
그런 게임입니다.
그게 결국에는
이 게임에서
아서 모건이 계속
딜레마에 빠지는 부분들이거든요.
게임 내내 아서 모건이
outlaws이긴 하지만
그럼에도 불구하고
자기 캠프에
어린 애들한테는
야
너는 이런 거 하지 말까
이런
스탠스잖아요.
랜이 이런 애들한테는
그러면서 자기는
자기가 하는 건 합당한 거예요.
자기가 가서
사람들 등 쳐먹고
피 묻히는 건 내가 하는 거야.
피 묻히는 건 다 자기가 하는 거고
그 어떤 모순되는
감정선과 이런 게
진짜로 기가 막히게 표현이 돼 있습니다.
이 게임에서
전기가 너무 좋군요.
그리고 제가 또 되게 좋아하는 장면 중에 하나가
그 상대 가문 중에
좀 계속 거슬리는 가문이 있거든요.
브레이스 웨이트라고
거기서 이 캠프에
정말 마스코트 격인
아이를 하나 잡아갑니다.
우리에게 이제 시비를 거는 거죠.
잭 마스터
근데 거기서
그 아이 아빠는
계속 돌아다니면서
밖에서 강도짓 할 것만
생각나면은 아서를 불러요.
그리고 와서
야 나 이번에
좋은 건수
좋은 건수 봤는데
그럼 같이
마차 털면서
야 그래도 아들은 좀 챙겨라
이러면
참고로 그 아빠가
레이더 드레스 원의 주인공입니다.
그렇죠.
근데 이제 그 아이가
그 브레이스 웨이트 가문에 잡혀왔습니다.
그때는
누가 말할 것도 없이 그냥
다 가죠.
모두가 다 챙겨요.
너무 멋있어요.
진짜로 그게 너무 멋있잖아요.
맞아.
아까 그 서태훈 감독하고
하이파이브 샷이랑 같은 거예요.
우리 평소에 맨날 싸우고 있으면
잭을 잡아놨잖아요.
그때 진짜 총 신나게 쐈습니다.
그렇죠.
작품성이 좋은데
도파민을 자극하는 그런 부분도
참 잘 챙겨놨다.
맞아요.
그래서 저는 이 게임이
락스타 게임 중에서도
또 최고의 명작이지 않았나
저에게도 그렇습니다.
그래서 이 게임이 주는 교훈이 있다면?
이 게임이 주는 교훈은
총을 빨리 뽑아야 된다.
남보다 빨리 뽑아야 된다는 거다.
선수 필수.
그러니까 이게 총이라는 거지.
뭔가를 할 때는 남보다 빨리
뽑을 거면.
그런 교훈이 있다.
내가 들어보면 가장 놀라운 교훈이네요.
너희들이 많이 얘기하는데.
작가님도 언젠가 빨리 뽑아야 될 때가 있습니다.
이건 누가 봐도 잘 만든 오픈월드잖아요.
잘 만든 오픈월드와
못 만든 오픈월드에 대한 차이점이 있을까요?
흔히 말해서 유비식이냐.
그 유비식이
락스타식이냐.
약간 이런 느낌이에요.
유비식이 돈 100원을 갖고 와라.
그다음에는 100원 없으면 너 죽여.
그러니까 이런 식으로 계속 똑같은 미션이 있는 거잖아요.
유비식 그거는.
네, 뺑뺑이.
유비식은 설렘이 없고
필요만 있는.
네, 맞아요.
뭘 해야 하는 의무만 있는.
그러니까 쉽게 말해서
제작진이 얼마나 노가다를 했느냐.
맞아요.
하나하나의 사이드캐스트 하나의 서사를 넣고
상호작용 넣고 하려면 진짜 엄청난 노가다가 필요하더라고요.
락스타라든지 CD 프로젝트라든지 그런 데들은
노가다를 엄청나게 많이 해가지고
누굴 만나도 다 서사가 있어.
저는 오픈월드에서
이 NPC스러움이 안 나타나는 게 정말 잘 만든 오픈월드인 것 같아요.
살아있는 사람인 것 같은 게.
실제 아소모건이 풀을 뜯어서 흩어가지고 주머니에 넣는 거 실시간으로 보여준다니까요.
얼마나 느려.
배고프면 정말로 산짐승 잡아가지고 고기 구워 먹고 캠프하면서.
다만 레데리가 입문하기 쉬운 게임은 아니잖아요.
그건 그래요.
캠프가 워낙 요즘 게임치곤 굉장히 느린 게임이기 때문에.
의도적인 불친절함으로 가득해요.
그리고 처음에 설산만 넘기면 되거든요.
그렇죠.
거기만 넘기면 무조건 갓게임을 보장할 수 있기 때문에.
꼭 해보십시오.
재용님 픽은?
네, 저는 몬스터헌터.
몬스터헌터.
나 너무 서운하다.
종범님도 몬스터헌터 너무 좋아하시잖아요.
너무 좋아하는데.
일단 몬스터헌터에 대해서 간단히 소개해 드리면.
몬스터헌터는 기본적으로 내가 헌터가 돼서 몬스터를 잡는 게임입니다.
그렇죠.
끝!
끝이야, 끝이야.
칼 하나 주고요.
갑자기 미션을 줘요.
새 좀 잡아와 이럽니다.
그러면 새가 일단 커요.
어떻게 어떻게 해가지고 새 패턴을 알아서 피하고 때리고 피하고 때리고 하다 보면 개를 죽죠.
그럼 개가 죽으면 그 새의 소재로 장비를 만듭니다.
그럼 내가 좀 더 세요.
더 세져요.
그러면 그 새 다음에 있는 공룡을 잡으러 가요.
뭐 이런 식으로.
그러니까 약간 실제로 이 세계의 게이트가 열려서 우리가 출퇴근하는 길에 몬스터가 나왔다고 상상을 해보고.
우린 정보가 없어.
근데 걔를 이제 잡아야 되는 입장이 된다고 하면 아마 이런 인터페이스를 거치겠구나.
그러니까.
조사해야 돼.
공부해야 돼.
준비해야 돼.
이게 너무 큰 게임이라 놀랐어요.
맞아요.
어떻게 보면 게임의 제작진들이 현실과 최대한 비슷한 리얼리즘을 살리고 싶었어요.
음.
인터페이스를 퍼판 몬스터 그리고 레벨을 올려서 내가 강해서 때리는 게 아니라
게이머의 숙련도가 올라가고 장비의 성능이 올라가고 그 두 가지로만 내가 강해지는 구조를 짠 거예요.
몬스터들에 남아 있는 체력을 안 보여주는 것도 굉장한 게임이에요.
안 보여줘요.
체력이 안 나와요.
이게 인생이다.
에너지 바가 없어요.
참고로 지금은 데미지 숫자도 나오는데 옛날에는 데미지 숫자가 없었어요.
죽으라고 언젠가 죽겠지 하고 때리는 거야.
그러다 보니까 옛날에는 그냥 몬스터를 잡을 때 날이 상하니까 이거 뭐야 숫돌질도 해야 되고.
고기도 그냥 나오는 게 아니라 옆에 있는 돼지 같은 걸 잡아가지고 고기를 잡는데 고기는 날 고기야.
화로에다가 구워야 되는데 그러면 음악이 나오거든요.
땡! 할 때 땡! 눌러야 돼요.
그때 빨리 누르면 덜 익은 고기 늦게 누르면 탈 고기가 나와요.
정확하게 그 익은 고기를 많이 해서 고기를 딱 만들어야 돼요.
희석이 요리를 되게 요리의 디테일을 굉장히 잘 그리거든요.
요리한 장면만큼은 넋어놓고 보게 돼요.
너무 먹음직스럽게 잘 묘사를 해 놔 가지고.
그 외에도 뭐.
쨍하게 불편함을 감수하면서 굉장히 힘든 만큼 내가 성취했을 때 얻는 쾌감이 엄청나게 크다.
쉽게 잊혀지지 않는다. 그 손맛이 어떻게 보면 우리 인생에는 필요한 것 아닌가.
매력이 있는 것 같습니다.
종범님 픽은 마인크래프트입니다.
마인크래프트. 모르는 사람 없는 게임입니다.
마지막까지 고민한 게 엘든링하고 마인크래프트였는데 사실은 저는 그동안 20몇 년을 콘솔만 하니까
살아있는 인간하고 같이 플레이하는 온라인 게임의 재미를 20몇 년 만에 다시 한 게 마인크래프트였습니다.
그런 맥락으로?
네. 근데 해봤더니 이거는 게임이라기보다는 월드 시뮬레이터구나.
이 게임을 제가 세계 시뮬레이터라고 생각하는 이유가 뭐냐면
내가 뭘 하고 싶은지 목표를 세우는 것부터가 이 게임의 시작이야.
예를 들면
나는 이 세계에서 종결 아이템 맞춰가지고 이 세계에서 진짜 센 애를 잡아볼 거야 이런 순간
그걸 위해서 예를 들면 이거예요.
장비를 만들기 위해서는 광물이 필요해.
광물을 만들기 위해서는 광질을 해야 돼.
광질을 하기 위해서는 최소한 도구가 필요해.
도구를 하기 위해서는 초보 단계의 도구가 필요해.
근데 그 결과 마지막에 결국은 내가 이 세계에 제일 어려운 몬스터를 잡았을 때
아무도 지키지 않았는데 그냥 내 마음이 이끄는 대로 목표로 세우고 가서 한 거잖아.
여기서 주는 어마어마한 성취감이 있습니다.
그냥 한마디로 표현하면 안 되는 게 없고 유일한 한계가 있다면 네 상상력이다.
하나씩 하나씩 만들어가는 과정이 있는데
그거 조금 하다 보면 내가 이 안에서 구현할 수 있는 모든 것들의 책을 딱 알게 돼요.
그거 하나씩 만들다 보면 어느새 이 게임에 좀 익숙한 유저가 되어 있는 상태인 거죠.
그쯤 친구들과 함께 하게 되는 것이 어떻게 보면 정석이라고 하죠.
건축물로 진짜 멋진 어떤 건물을 구현해보고 싶다.
그런 사람들은 혼자 하기도 하는데
같이 할 때가 진짜 재밌는 게 있어요.
제가 마인크래프트 찍먹했다가 실패한 이유가
친구가 없어서.
40대에 가장 큰 문제예요.
40대는 친구가 없어요.
40대에 새로 마인크래프트 하는 사람을 찾기가 어렵고
파티원 찾기 어려워요.
그리고 저 같은 경우도 이제 아까 작가님 얘기하신 것처럼
막 이렇게 가가지고 혼자서 자원을 해가지고 좀 알아갈 때쯤에
정말 나의 칠칠치 못한 실수로 모든 걸 다 잃어버릴 때가 있잖아요.
그냥 졸면서 한순간 낙사해서 죽거나 용암에 빠져서 내가 만든 게 사라졌어.
세이브가 없어요?
그런 게 없습니다.
인생에 세이브가 있나요?
난 근데 그 순간 인생을 배워요.
진짜 메타버스네.
진짜 메타버스예요.
메타버스죠 저건.
진주랑 하늘에 따라 완전 다른 삶이 될 수 있는.
그래서 지금 저희 같이 하는 친구들 중에는 죽을 위험이 아예 없는 농사꾼으로 살아보겠다는 애가 있어요.
그 친구는 죽을 위험이 없잖아요.
근데 자원이 필요해요.
그럼 저 같은 모험가에게 부탁을 해요.
그럼 나는 모험가니까 죽을 위험이 있잖아요.
그럼 농사에서 지은 걸 다 저한테 줘가지고 먹여주고.
그런 식으로 각자가 자기 역할을 하면서 마을을 만들어 나가면 되죠.
친구가 일단 있어야겠네요.
친구가 중요해.
아니 마크로 친구를 사귈 수도 있어요.
친구 어렵다.
그거는 좀 못 믿겠어요.
쉽지 않죠.
40대에 새로운 친구 사귀기 쉽죠.
40대에 인터넷으로 친구 사귀는 거 좀 어렵죠.
아무튼 마음만 친구 있다고 하면 마크는 저는 진짜 강추할 만한 게임입니다.
아무튼 오늘 입문자들을 위해서 최애 게임 설명회를 좀 진행을 해봤는데요.
입문자를 위한 거였어요?
그러니까 오늘 좀 어려운 얘기 많이 나왔는데.
전혀 입문자를 위한 게임.
그렇다고 저희가 캔디 크러쉬를 할 순 없었죠.
작가님은 갓겜은 어떤 조건을 갖춰야 된다고 생각하십니까?
저는 갓겜을 어떤 정해져 있는 몇 가지 외부적 규칙으로 정리하는 것이 가장 안타까운 일이라고 보고
나의 인생에 줬던 임팩트가 얼마나 큰가를 가지고 구분하는 게 맞다고 봐요.
그래서 나만의 기준으로 생기는 게 아니라
이게 각자의 갓겜이라는 생각이 들어요.
이거 좀 예민할 수도 있는 질문일 수 있는데
그 라스트 오브 어스 2 같은 경우에
갓겜입니다. 저한테.
저한테는 인생 게임인데 모두가 미워하죠.
어떤 사람들은 이게 자신들의 기대와 좀 저버리는 스토리 방향 라인이었잖아요.
감정적 학대를 받았다고 고백하는 유저들이 많았을 만큼
많은 이들을 힘들게 했지만 그런 의미에서 나에게는 갓겜이었던 거죠.
와 나는 이런 체험을 할 수 있는 기회가 어디에서도 없었는데
네.
이런 상실감, 이런 복수심, 그리고 이런 창자를 끊는 용서의 순간을
게임을 통해 처음 해본 거예요.
저는 이게 저한테 갓겜이죠.
남한테는 절대 아니거든요. 그런 느낌?
그럼 간지 님이 생각하시는 좋은 게임도 한번 얘기해볼까요?
아 제가 생각하는 좋은 게임?
일단은 저는
이 만드시는 분들이 정말 이 게임을 사랑하는 마음이 좀 있었으면 좋겠다.
그러니까 이게 어떤 수치로 보여지는 것도 아니지만
음악도,
음악도 마찬가지로 내가 이 음악 좋아하는데
어? 너도 이 음악 좋아하니? 라고 하면 서로 느끼는 어떤 기류 같은 게 있잖아요.
게임도 저는 제작자와 플레이어들이 분명히 그걸 느낄 수 있는 기류가 있다고 생각해요.
그래서 이 만들었을 때
야, 내가 이렇게 잘 만들어봤는데 한번 해보지 않을래?
그러면 내가 해봤을 때 무조건 느낄 수 있을 거라는 생각이 있어요.
표현하자면 약간 덕후의 소울이 느껴지는
그렇죠. 저는 조금
음악이 됐든 미술이 됐든 소리가 좀.
좀 덕후? 음악이 됐든 미술이 됐든 소리가 좀.
덕후가 만든 거면 좀 좋아하는 경향이에요.
저는 게임을 제 작품이라고 생각을 하거든요.
그럼요.
이런 작품들이 더 많이 나오면 좋겠다.
아무튼 오늘 소감을 한번 들어보겠습니다.
사실은 40대들이랑 게임 얘기할 수 있는 자리가 많지 않아요.
많지 않죠, 진짜.
파티원 구하기도 쉽지 않고.
거의 어디 무슨 재활센터에서나 많을 것 같아요.
이렇게 같은 어떤 기억을 공유하는 사람들을 만나기가 쉽지 않은데
오늘은 어떻게 보면 저는 그냥
재미는 좀 내려놓고
그냥 과거에 시간여행을 떠나갔다 온
오락실에서 동전 걸었던 그 얘기부터 시작해서
시간여행을 너무 즐겁게 갔다 온 것 같아서
마음이 너무 좋습니다.
사실은 비주류 경제작이 CG 바뀌어가지고
분위기가 사뭇 달라졌다고 느끼는데
이런 분위기의 대화도 재밌네요.
재밌죠.
오히려 좀 제가 내려놓을 수 있게 해주신 것 같아서
너무 편안하게 얘기하고 간다는 느낌이라서
감사드립니다.
그러니까요.
요즘 머니그래피가
이 방법이거든요.
포스트를 이렇게 해서
야, 내가 여기서 아무 말이나 해도 쟤보다는 낫겠다.
네.
너무 편하게 수다 떨고 갑니다.
감사합니다.
그럼 오늘 비주류 초대석
오늘은 채용 님, 이종범 작가님과
게임 이야기를 신나게 떠들어봤고
저희는 다음 시간에
다음 주제로
다른 주제로
재미있게 돌아오도록 하겠습니다.
감사합니다.
인사드릴까요?
안녕.